the peace in Kashmir has once again been
interrupted as the anger in tensions
over the region grows check-posts Raisa
why and restrictions in place thousands
of paramilitary personnel and police man
the streets
as we travel through a locked-down City
our vehicle is stopped and checked every
few hundred meters by security forces in
anticipation of any trouble the
government instructed tourists and Hindu
pilgrims to cut short their stay and
leave the valley it caused further panic
amongst thousands of temporary workers
who are fleeing the state now a
precautionary measure after the central
government revoked article 370 of the
Indian Constitution it guaranteed the
people of Kashmir ownership in property
and state jobs among other privileges on
the streets the decision has brought
widespread fear and a sense of betrayal
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people especially with Eid
around the corner but today and for the
last few days since the time article 370
was revoked
it's absolutely deserted hundreds of
people took to the streets after Friday
prayers in the capital carrying black
flags and chanting anti-india slogans
this was the first large protest
uncertainty is further fueled by a
complete communications blackout
internet mobile and phone services have
been cut off the Indian government said
article 370 was a temporary measure in
the Constitution and has outlived itself
now Kashmir will be directly governed by
Delhi it represents a betrayal and not
just a betrayal of the people of Kashmir
it is a betrayal of the Indian
Constitution I mean this is I can't say
that loudly enough you know because
that's what the Constitution says the
Constitution of India also says that you
cannot change the structure the
territory etc of the state you know of
any state in India without consulting
the people
as people absorb their new status they
are hurting and the tension is palpable
Kashmir was the only Muslim majority
state in India the real fear for people
here is without the protection of a
special status the demography will
change never Lazarus Sky News in
Srinagar Kashmir